[Music]
to make the diving board shell workers
load a sheet of acrylic into a clamping
machine that transports it into an oven
the oven heats the sheet for about 30
seconds to soften it then a forming
machine applies suction to draw the
softened acrylic tightly over a mold in
the shape of two diving boards fans blow
cool air hardening the acrylic to this
shape within seconds they extract the
molded acrylic then solid in half to
separate the two diving board shells
they coat the shell surface in a resin
and fiberglass mixture this tool is
called a chopper gun because it chops
and shreds the fiberglass string then
shoots it out drenched and resin they
roll it to compress the fibers and push
out air pockets any trapped air would
create a weak spot in the diving board
after letting the resin dry and harden
for 30 minutes
they begin filling the shell cavity with
2/10 of an inch thick fiberglass mat
then they lay down another fiberglass
mat this one a bit thinner and saturated
with the existing resin the diving
boards core is made of laminated wood
which is several thin layers of wood
glued together laminated wood is
actually stronger than a solid piece of
wood after rounding the top edge they
lay two wood laminate cores over the
resin saturated fiberglass mats
they position clamps to hold the cores
in place then let the resin cure at room
temperature for a half hour or so then
the clamps come off and workers cover
the cores with an even thicker
fiberglass mat impregnated with resin
this is the bottom of the diving board
[Music]
they make sure the mat is centered then
manually form it to the shape of the
board pushing out the air pockets as
they go they spray on some decorative
paint then put the board in an oven for
24 hours to cure when it comes out they
use a diamond blade to Saul off the
excess fiberglass around the edge then
they do a final trimming to make the
edge neat and smooth they mask the sides
with tape leaving only the top exposed
this is where they'll now apply a rough
texture a safe non-slip surface first
they roll on a thin coat of resin onto
that they sprinkle a layer of silica
sand making sure to cover the surface
thoroughly and evenly the sand sticks to
the resin which sets and cures in about
15 minutes after sweeping off the excess
sand that didn't it here they roll on a
coat of laminating resin which bonds to
the sand giving the surface a clean
finished look
[Music]
they pull off the tape and apply the
manufacturers decal to the side the
diving board is now all set to be
installed on a stand at the edge of the
deep end to await anyone ready to take
the plunge
[Music]
Oh